this is my first viewing he's actually
already seen it I've seen it I refuse to
see it after the goddamn second preview
for the first Alice movie I said no this
is not Alice in Wonderland I'm sure this
is even less like a also Wonderland but
I have not seen it through the
looking-glass you are in for a treat oh
I'm so excited so friggin excited I did
not hate this one as much as the first
one as a shit sandwich this one grabs a
little better okay perhaps a little
better it's a little better shit but
it's still shit yeah so let's just do it
you know what don't even Disney don't
try to make this magical this is not
gonna be fun
this is gonna be homework yeah that
castle just needs to blow up Alice in
Wonderland this straight some punch ah
here we go
yeah don't you totally believe she's a
sea captain can't you see that she would
command absolute authority her
personality was so strong in the last
one his Catholic King Shia LeBoeuf is
like the head of a military organization
or something it's like no no I'm a
five-star general the only way to
achieve the impossible is to believe it
is possible a talking cat taught me that
what a talking cat yeah that title so
goes with what we just saw so stupid it
was Ella's through the straits of
maracas remember when Peter Griffin did
the King and I and he had like Anna was
like this giant robot that spelled out
Anna this is what that is like through
the looking-glass my fucking ass they
brought you back to huh guess we're both
stuck in this film together time is
cruel must do you'll be remembering that
like two hours into the movie I look
here what if she's still not that
interesting but by god there is much
more facial expression her and Sasha
Baron Cohen are probably the best things
in this movie everyone else does it fail
oh I'm pompous you can tell cuz my nose
is up in my mouth is Evan huh
oh you are dressed like the NBC Peacock
how was it the world yes you should
visit it sometime
he's like a family guy caricature all of
this - the humor is a family guy they
are actually acting goofier than like
all the people in the last movie there's
an idea do Alice in Wonderland that's
the opposite somebody from Wonderland
ghosts of this world and things if it is
like crazy like let's I know what the
book does because it works on levels and
layers and this is just one level one
layer dumb oh my god this guy's my hero
but this actually has wondered to it I
know that was like to be wider no no no
it's a cool weird shit like I liked this
part yeah no no no we can't have this
there has to be like boring talks and
talks of rebellion that's Alice of
Wonderland we can't have this nonsense
there you go you do The Princess Diaries
twice and then they own you he looks
really lost like goofy huh right that's
right we get to go into the Hatters
backstory shit I say he looks like a
Dark Shadows character except he
actually goddamn played a Dark Shadows
character I can't tell which I find
creepier his willy wonka at Mad Hatter I
just assumed I was looking at Willy
Wonka is this in that Hatter yep the sad
hi I shit you not
this is the fucking plot it had said we
gotta make him happy again
that's the fucking plot - this pencil
look of Johnny Depp trying to remember
his lines did I wait man like the
world's worst Irish clown
she belongs in The Wizard of Oz she's
always doing this this is her likes
tacos everyone looks like they were just
kind of pushed in at the last minute
yeah make it up it looks like they
literally pulled Ivan from a bar or the
craft services table like bagels still
in him like this will take you
tamati I think I really want to do that
do story why was he with the Frog why
was the athlete were they married but
was that male or female froggy is there
gay marriage and you know under lamp I
mean it's kind of interesting
everyone pots with everything eventually
my dear movie franchises hot with the
series in doing your career good now
we're in robots remember that Rabelais
was moving up actually that was the most
horrifying realization been like when
Sasha Baron Cohen feels like he's too
good for your movie Wow did you fuck up
somewhere cuz I'm like I want him in a
better movie I treasure it forever I'm
like Tim who keeps throwing Mimi's films
not the chromosphere wasn't even that
good of a video game
who's Ellis it's like a shit see the
beginning of the movie paid off it
wasn't just stupid it was stupid for a
latest DBZ but still let us just recap
so what else has done with fucking bitch
Anne Hathaway's blessing place to the
Bezier just yes destroy the entire
Wonderland slash under land because
you're stupid and you were called into
one with lemon it's really on the lens
when dear agony is beautiful adventure
gets such a high budget also more Alice
in Wonderland yeah
oh my god it was him what why was there
such a build-up to that if this was
Alice in Wonderland
I'm from the future you'd be okay what
do we do like that mad that's crazy
fat Alice in Wonderland Johnny Depp
actually got nominated for this it was a
Razzie right yeah
between the clock king and the
production design I I do actually like
this bill better than the first one
yeah I'll admit I I can get through this
one so far and get to this one easier
good and you're gonna be face palming a
lot but Alice in Wonderland but others
clearly isn't it never mind she took
something from me not important it is a
trifle but I don't see why you're making
such a fuss he's the most Wonderland
thing in the fucking series in both
films so all these characters were just
always friends yeah I can't really think
of it as like kids ever I just meant to
be always kind of because I know right
it's like I don't want to think of them
as kids that's that's because you're
thinking of Wonderland when clearly this
is under wow there's the most boring
young Mad Hatter I've ever seen and I've
only seen one as a kid it's gotta be
like crazy goofy wait like this kid
should be bouncing up and down like
flubber boy should be like Daffy Duck
yeah look my accent is inexplicably
British even though later I'm gonna be
like some weird Scottish and Irish
French hybrids hatching is a serious
business and wonderla Underland I feel
so sorry for this guy so do like I was
just doing my job
you would stupid kit.3 is a C total
illnesses
how to tie a bloody good note why didn't
you even need to say that could have
figured that out how can she do that
she's but a blonde lady like what do we
need to know do that she's a sailor
Tucker madam
peso Oh pointless absolutely pointless
all the fun you could have with that
with her in a mental ward yep fucking
wasted time our anti-heroes literally
act my heroes on the way I would be
excited to see the Mad Hatter's
exploring hat and just how boring is
that that run - one thing I've learned
being a sailors never carry a weapon
into a dangerous situation where's that
line that's the one that needs
explaining
oh you think it's up to you now Alice
god help me it's up to you you who've
earned my yes are you at least happy now
you're not sad because all of this was
for that tension it I'm a little bit
upset chatter one time dies I see a
movie so we were dead I guess we're
gonna talk about this did you have the
freakishly and holy vision of hell - no
mine was like watching rather Chopin I'm
not really okay was Catholic watching
that wow that's really different
[Music]
she never tell him no you should see the
role she turned out about this the
villains the people that just screwed up
everything all these movies didn't need
to happen all this suffering everything
was yeah Alice and the White Queen yeah
it's treating it like no there's still
the heroes I'm like oh you know it there
is a very strict no Alice's allowed sign
above the door put it there immediately
after I got my consciousness back out I
am warning you now I have 30 automatic
gun turrets
trained on you you have five seconds to
leave
is he fucking doing it like got worse in
between the two movies I don't think he
was sober through no I don't think he
was sober at all he's actually not
wearing any makeup you know what when
you're gonna show up with makeup I don't
think that was coming out something
different you can't you shall form the
shipping firm of Kingsley and you can't
be serious
she gets like two minutes out of porn
and all of us in the white rabbit schism
the man who has a headache the better
movie isn't that not good not a good
movie oh definitely not another matter
but there are there are elements of
Alice in Wonderland at least in the
attitudes once in a while I don't mourn
for the movie that could have been had
you just focus on Sacha Baron Cohen's
character third is stupid not stupid yo
one not as anger inducing but still
perfect stupid it was pretty it was a
pretty movie yeah that's why I said
pretty stupid so we'll see you next time
ah but Doug time is all we have maybe
something something you will learn
something you can't change the past even
though you cannot stop it pretty stupid
though you didn't buy by number no max
that's good goodbye ja a fetus
you